hi i am emily blunt and i play dr lily
houghton
who gives it and i'm dwayne johnson and
i play frank i'm only kidding yeah
and i play frank wolf in disney's jungle
cruise
and today we're gonna play a game of who
is who
who's who jesus no it's just my accent
who's most likely to be caught napping
between takes actually it's usually me
during dwayne's close-up
[Laughter]
oh that was good is that right yeah is
that how we're going to play
that's the game we're going to play okay
here we go watch this
who's most likely to win a game of
disney trivia
that would be me because she has never
been to disney and
how many disney movies have you been in
now three okay i've been in four
no you haven't four tooth fairy was
disney no game plan race to wichita
watch baywatch
okay uh moana that's true can i say
except
who's most likely to survive a real-life
jungle cruise adventure
that would be new because you have more
fat on you
so you'd last longer
look at everybody's head popped up what
listen always bring your bell tricks to
the gym
who's most likely to know everyone
else's lines me he barely knows his own
mind
looks like there's not no lines at all
just for context for everybody at
buzzfeed by the way
what no i'm just saying when i come onto
set you never know your lines do i have
words
yeah am i saying words pages what am i
saying like who's most likely to nail a
stunt on the first take i will say him
because it takes me a very long time to
learn a stunt sequence and he is like a
ballet dancer he comes in
he goes show me the moves and you nail
it and i haven't got anything nice
you're very kind just keep it there
thank you very much
who's most likely who's most likely to
break
out into laughter in the middle of a
tank i have no self-control i feel that
you
are humorless
oh that's so good who's most likely to
be caught taking a selfie guys
come on no that would be me of course
that would be me because you're not on
social media that's the only thing
that's on your phone
you're not cool okay oh i have mystique
who's most likely to randomly burst into
song what can i say
only with his own songs oh really yeah
no i don't want to sing it i don't want
to sing sam cook no i don't
i don't another time no you can't you'll
sing now
you'll sing now and you're like who's a
control freak who's most likely to be a
controller dwayne johnson who's most
likely to invite the cast over for a
dinner party
i mean this is almost absurd he has no
friends
he doesn't even know how to throw it and
that would be emily it would be me yes
who's most likely to call the other via
facetime i'd say me
yeah most likely to not answer
facetime no come on you always pick up
my calls i do
yeah is that it oh man it's going good
hey that's fun that's fun i like the
imperfections
[Music]
you